all right everybody welcome back we are
inside of cinema 4d here and we are
going to take a look at some kind of
different common lighting setups and
what they mean and when to use them this
is a model that i found on art station
so i won't be able to provide this for
you guys i am going to provide this
project file so that you guys can
actually bring in your own models and
i'll i'll kind of show you where to get
those once we actually get into uh the
scene where we actually need to build
out
uh our specific thing so i chose this
model specifically because of the amount
of detail and everything because i
really wanted to emphasize how important
it is
to
uh control the shadows in the image to
make it look not only more realistic but
more visually appealing the first
lighting setup that we are going to set
uh talk about is
the most simple uh lighting setup that
you will come across inside of cinema 4d
and that's just front frontal lighting
and
this is as you can see it really kind of
flattens out the image and basically
gives highlight
to all the detail inside of the
characters
face there
now
this
isn't necessarily a
um lighting setup that i recommend uh as
you can see for the most part other than
the character and the amount of appeal
in the uh character the detail and
appeal in the character's face it's seen
it's very flat and it's very it's kind
of boring now when would you want to use
this type of lighting so
this type of lighting is actually mainly
uh focused on things if there's
something specific in the character's
face that you need to highlight so for
instance if this character had a
specific face tattoo or a particular
detail of jewelry
things of that sort where everything
needs to be in fully and lit this is
probably you know one of the best
lighting setups to go with but that is
very for a very very specific reason if
we are talking about cinematic lighting
maybe for portrait lighting this could
work uh well for you because you do have
to highlight you want to highlight as
much detail and show as much of the
information in the face as possible
you're not really trying to control
shadow there you're more trying to
highlight the detail in the face
so that would be a scenario where you
would kind of use this particular type
of lighting just to let you guys know
too i am working in octane and the
reason why i am doing that is because uh
being able to
jump back and forth into different
lighting setups is going to make this a
little bit easier um
than the physical renderer and i don't
want you guys uh
have to sit around and wait for me to uh
let this render as we uh talk about
these particular lighting setups so uh
yeah so that is frontal lighting and
that is mainly the type of situations
that you would want to use that for so
like i said i never use this i probably
will in the future it once i start
getting into more character creation and
development like zbrush and creating you
know custom models like this but as for
now
i don't use this particular type of
lighting but it is useful in some
applications
so let's go ahead and move to our next
lighting setup and the next lighting
setup is called
split lighting so as you can see here
with split lighting
we have our main light that is sitting
right here to the complete side of the
face
of our character
and as you can see what happens here is
that we see some detail we see most of
the detail on the right side of the
character and then that character kind
of starts to
fall off into the shadows now this is a
very interesting type of lighting setup
because this also allows you to
create this sense of mysteriousness but
also revealing who the character is we
don't know who fully they are but we can
see that this character you know is
some type of horned individual seems
kind of menacing uh probably some type
of fantasy type of creature or a being
so
that is uh essentially how this lighting
is working where you know everything
kind of falls off to the shadow and we
only see one side of the face so i don't
see this lighting too often i mainly see
this type of lighting in such genres
like horror or mystery
uh something where we are trying to
accentuate a certain level of
mysteriousness in our character let's go
ahead and move to our next lighting
setup now the next sighting lighting
setup we have is called fill lighting
now
if we take off the uh you know the left
light now we we're back into our kind of
split lighting
ordeal here now the common lighting
setup that you will find mostly in the
real world uh the most common thing that
you'll hear about is three-point
lighting um and three-point lighting is
where you have your key light which is
what
our current light here on the light is
acting as that is going to be
the
most intense light that is on the
subject now your key light one thing
that i
was confused about when learning about
lighting and how to set up lights when i
was in film school was i couldn't i
didn't know okay does it matter if the
key light is on the fill or on the right
or the left does that really matter
no it doesn't uh your key light just
remember is the light that is going to
get the highest amount of intensity on
your subject so that is your main light
if we want to add in some more detail
mainly what i did was as i added in
what's called a fill light and that fill
light if we look at the
left light here
let's go into our settings here the
key light is at a power of 15 but i go
to my fill right that is at a power of
one and that is just to bring in a
little bit more information and here on
the side now this is one of the most
common lighting setups that you'll see
easiest lighting setups that you'll see
in cg and also in filmmaking
another thing with this type of lighting
which is uh if we wanted to add to it
and make it a three-point lighting setup
we would basically just take one of
these lights and we'll put it to the
back and i'll show you what that looks
like so
what we're going to do is we are going
to take our
fill light and we're going to duplicate
it
i'm just going to hit control hold
control and drag my light to the top and
now i'm just going to
hit r and then i'm going to rotate it
hold down shift until it hits 90 degrees
there and then we're going to position
it behind
our main character here and
let that show us what we get
let me um
make sure we're doing this properly and
then i'm going to
raise it and let's let's add in
um
let's add in some more power
and as you can see
what's happening here is that
backlighting our backlight is giving
some nice
light uh more dimension to our
character here by highlighting these
edges which is a really nice effect so
let's turn that off so
we can see let's go one by one actually
excuse me
okay
so this is our split lighting and we see
our key light then we add in a little
bit more
um um
whoops
wrong one we added a little bit more
fill to kind of
enlighten some of the information on his
face here and to kind of separate it
from its background another thing or
what we did is we added in a
background light and we'll just call
this vg light
for now
and so that gives this really nice kind
of you can see where those details are
coming out on the edges and everything
like that so that that is a really
common
very very good lighting setup usually uh
just for you know best practices what
i'll do is instead of having the light
not best practices excuse me this is
personal preference because i like the
way that indirect lighting actually
makes the character look instead of
actually pointing and i'll show you what
i talk about what i'm talking about here
instead of pointing my light directly at
my character like this
sometimes what i like to do is we'll
create a let's create a plane
i'm gonna hit uh r on the keyboard and
i'm gonna hold down shift to rotate
until it's
oops hold down shift and then it'll snap
to 90 degrees
i'm going to put this to the back of my
character
and we are going to throw on a yellow
texture
and then what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take my light and instead of uh
let me let me
spare it with me here i'm going to put a
octane
oops wrong tag
40 tags
okay object tag i am going to
turn it off in the camera and then what
i'm going to do is i'm going to grab my
background light and i'm going to rotate
it and i'm going to have it hit
this back wall here we'll do 180 degrees
remember hold down shift
to get that to snap
and then i'm going to spread the light
out
and i actually need to go back into my
camera since
this is how octane works
and
we're going to really crank up the light
on the background here and we should
start to see
if i'm doing this properly we still
should start to see some of the yellow
light kind of bouncing onto our
character so
uh and you can see that happening right
here
it's not as effective as i would like so
maybe what i need to do is and oh yeah
you can see it right there
it looks like the light itself is kind
of uh
blocking my object so let's uh
not oh okay i think i know what i need
to do
let's uh
let's just raise the light up
and then we're gonna rotate it
and then
we need to
kind of move it like that
i think that's going to give me a better
result so it's not super sexy but
you'll get the point
so if i come here now
that back lighting is giving me that
extra added detail
but it's actually indirect lighting and
it's a little bit softer it's not as
it's it blends a little bit better with
the shadows as opposed to when you saw
the
direct lighting remember we talked about
indirect and direct lighting the direct
lighting hitting the the model actually
caused these really sharp transitions in
the lighting between the shadows and his
the edges on his face and the edges on
his body but as you can see that
indirect lighting is kind of smoothly
uh transitioning into the shadows of the
character so that's a that's another way
of actually adding in that extra added
depth and using color so we'll go more
into that later so let's go ahead and
get rid of that plane
and we're going to move into our next
lighting setup which is the badger
and let's go to no colors
and
[Music]
let's
back out of our camera here and
a badger lighting
as you can see is set up this way where
we have two lights of even intensity if
we look at the lights here
we look at their intensity
they're both going to be at
15. up here to the right so you can see
that we get this kind of opposite effect
when we are doing then what we were
doing with the split lighting where the
side of his face was in shadow now
what's happening is the opposite the
sides of the face are actually uh
illuminated and now the complete front
of his face is in a darkness so
this is uh what's called a badger
lighting i think this type of lighting
is super uh cinematic i love it it
reveals just enough detail inside of the
character's um face
that
it can still make it visually appealing
but it also creates this sensitive
mysteriousness and gives it more
definition the bot the the eye kind of
just falls back as it looks over you
know kind of the the
topology of the model so
badger lighting i think is really really
cool um this is another lighting setup
that is used to give a sense of
mysteriousness
and usually it's pretty you know
straightforward on where we actually
place those now one thing we can do is
if we wanted to change you know how the
lighting is falling always remember we
have other options here so let me go to
my cinema 4d tags i'm going to add a
target tag to both of my
uh light setups here and then we are
going to uh place our
main character in that target so that
the light continues to focus on it
i'm going to grab both my lights and i'm
just going to start to move them up
and kind of notice what happens
as i move those
lights simply by moving the position of
where they are the lighting and the the
kind of message of the story trains
quite dramatically so if we look here
and we look at the um i'm lighting let
me uh do that
let's go back into here
back down
if you look here you know there's a
pretty big difference on
you know the story that we're telling
once we move the lights kind of above
our character as opposed to
what they look like
you know here
so there's much different story being
told now you can also go in the opposite
direction we can kind of start to move
our lighting beneath and you can even
see it here
now we have a completely different
lighting setup and that tells us
kind of a different story within this
character so definitely
play with the positions of your lights
once you have them you know this is kind
of one of those things where you set up
the base you set up your framework and
then you manipulate it once you
understand the rules you can start
breaking those rules on the particular
lighting setups everything i have in
this project file
is a jumping off point for you okay so
definitely you know start with these and
then start manipulating them adding
color
for instance one of the interesting ways
that uh like we saw in the last example
adding color can
really change you know
how you're viewing the object so now we
have more of a story to tell because now
the color is telling me okay this seems
like this character is in some type of
cyberpunk maybe
futuristic city with
artificial fluorescent lighting uh maybe
a city scene maybe in tokyo japan or
something like that we start to get an
understanding of the actual setting uh
not only is this character mysterious
but the also location is kind of
mysterious because we can see this
really uh um kind of stylized specific
lighting look that's usually associated
with things like cyberpunk uh but we
don't see any environment he's
completely in darkness and we can't see
the full features of his face so this is
another way to actually start bringing
out a kind of a story inside of your
inside of your renders so the next thing
we're going to look at is loop lighting
okay
and let me uh back out of the camera so
you can get a bird's eye view of what we
have here so loop lighting
is basically
if we look
we have this like kind of like a
triangle uh uh kind of starting to form
here and we have this kind of triangle
here on the neck
so this is loop lighting where the light
this this um so let me let me open this
up so we can kind of see the intensity
and all that so the back lighting here
is at a 20 intensity
and this light
to the right is at the similar intensity
but the back lighting
uh is slightly off centered from the
character
as you can see
it's off centered from the character and
kind of pointing this way and the
uh
fill light um excuse me the key light as
you can see
the closest light to the character
giving the most intensity on the face is
actually raised slightly above and what
that's doing is is it's pushing
um it's pushing the shadows kind of
directionally down into the right so if
i kind of move
the light down here we start to move the
shadows
uh to the left
uh this way here
and then you know as we go down the
shadows will start to move up
into the angle and so on and so forth so
we'll just demonstrate that if i move
down now you can see
the shadows are starting to be pushed up
and now we have a completely different
look just by moving that down so let's
see
what other look we would get let's go
back to our camera let's back out of our
camera let's see what kind of look we
get by just moving this back light so if
i move this back light down
you know
we start to lose some of the detail here
he starts to become a little bit more
mysterious and then he starts to fall
into the shadows again i think this is
kind of cool how the light on the right
here is hitting the horn blocking it but
we can kind of get this swath remember
controlling your shadows is very
important making an image look
interesting we see this kind of little
sloth of light coming over the edge
over the um over the ear of the
character and then we also still get
this little highlight edge highlight of
the character to give a little bit of
detail so
those are that is what's called loop
lighting and i actually really like this
lighting setup i think it's pretty cool
so
we'll go ahead and move on to the next
lighting setup
this is probably going to be the most
common lighting setup this is called
rembrandt lighting
and as you can see with rimback excuse
me what rim burnt lighting is is a
light
source coming from one
excuse me lighting coming from one light
source
so it's not quite like split lighting
because we are not directly
to the
uh profile shot of our character as you
can see we're actually a little bit to
the left because we actually want to
reveal more information what ends up
happening and then we we pull the
lighting up as like we saw as in the
last example as the light goes up the
shadows will directionally pull into the
opposite direction of wherever the
light's going of course you know that by
you know just having human eyes
which you see every day but i just kind
of want to reiterate that information
and by pushing this up we actually start
to form this triangle where
the nose the cheek
and the side of the face and the top of
the eye actually form this little oasis
of light where everything else is
actually in shadow and that's how you
know you're actually doing rembrandt
lighting correctly rembrandt lighting
was obviously created or coined from the
artist rembrandt and rembrandt mainly
created this lighting when he was
painting because he was trying to figure
out how to paint light and shadows from
a light source that was on or from
lighting that was only coming from one
light source and usually that light
source was like a candlelight or
something like that
so uh and that's how he learned how to
draw because he knew that if i can get
the shadows to kind of form this
triangle on the cheek here
i think he he felt that that made the
image beautiful so this is what is known
as rembrandt lining very popular in
portraits used quite often
let's move on to the next one
which is
butterfly lighting
and if you look at butterfly lighting
it's a little bit similar to frontal
lighting
except with butterfly lighting
we have one light source that's actually
full in front of the character but it's
actually to the top and angled up and
what that's doing is you know that
you're doing the butterfly effect uh the
butterfly lighting effect correctly when
under the nose of your character you
start to see this kind of like what dark
kind of butterfly wedge here under the
nose and you also see this kind of sharp
shadow coming from the chin because the
light is up and the directionals of the
shadows are going down
butterfly lighting i think is highly
underutilized i don't i don't see it
used as much um and i i'm going to try
to actually utilize it more in my work
but as you can see it's very it's very
beautiful
you still get some a little bit there's
not much mystery left but we do have
some nice shadows falling off into the
side of the face we also have some
really cool shadows here
under the eyes uh and under the nose
this type of lighting is also best to
use for portraits of characters who
don't really have a strong
jawline
this character does have a straw strong
jawline but if you want to kind of
accentuate that jawline and make that
character's face kind of stand out more
and they don't have this butterfly
lighting is the best way to do that
because it does create this kind of like
shadow underneath the chin which
actually will separate it from the rest
of the uh the body so
very cool lighting style love it
okay so our next lighting setup that i
wanted to talk about are kind of like my
favorite lighting uh uh scenarios um
that i like to use
and i don't really have a name from this
i kind of just this is my setup like i
said so we're gonna
start with our top light
let me go back into our camera
so here's our top light and turn this
off and as you can see
you know we have
kind of similar to the
butterfly lighting so this is a
combination of a few things we have some
butterfly lighting going on here right
and it is uh
creating the nice little butterfly under
the nose we got some shadows here
there's a lot of information still being
revealed but you know it's at an
intensity of let's say 35
and that's where that sits in my scene
kind of like
directly above and angled down
to give me a sharp edge on my chin also
and then i have my back lighting which
is this type of lighting which will once
it's finished you'll notice it's similar
to our our badger lighting so
turn that back on you can see it's it's
to the back but it's also very similar
to our loop lighting because it's a
little off-centered
to our character so if i turn that off
you see how it actually brings in a
little bit of the more edge detail
that's back here on the left excuse me
on the right
so i'll turn that back on and you know
we just added more information there it
looks a little bit nicer this one's kind
of falling off into the shadows here so
same thing i added a light to the right
uh this is going to be at
i get i have them all at the similar
intensity which is fine and then now we
kind of have filled in that side there
and we do still have some nice shadows
coming from the top
of our main light here but we also have
our back shadows kind of giving us some
dimension and we can see our character
kind of fall off into the light i think
this is one of my favorite lighting
setups that i like to use when i'm doing
any type of portrait to kind of reveal
any detail in the face and the lips and
kind of still keep this sense of
mysteriousness
okay
let's move on to another
example color in lighting is
as i've as i've come to learn uh more
and more about lighting and cg is
very very important uh when you're
trying to actually tell a story so it's
good to understand what the capabilities
of using color are so now
um as you can see i have this kind of uh
top lighting coming down and there is a
lot of mystery in what's going on in
this shot first of all like we still
spoke about before uh with this type of
lighting setup with color we're trying
to figure out what the environment is
where's this light coming from what what
light source is actually producing this
light so that's you know trying to uh
tell a story we also don't fully know
what's going on with the character
inside the frame they're very dark and
mysterious uh we can't tell if they're
angry we can't tell if they're neutral
uh
and uh that that also kind of helps tell
a story
so the other one is
simply by taking the light
and then moving it forward now we
actually have revealed a lot more
information about our character and
we've pretty much used the shadows of
the horns to kind of wrap around and
frame the important parts of the
character's face which are the eyes the
nose and the mouth right here
simply by just taking you know
let's uh grab our back light and i'm
just going to demonstrate this live
simply by just taking our backlight and
moving that forward
now we have a completely different
lighting setup we understand you know
who our character is more so because we
can see more features in their face
we're still a little bit in the out of
the loop on what lighting source is
actually
causing this color tint on our character
and i'm going to show you guys how to
get this kind of lighting to i mean even
right there just moving it directly
above it we get a completely different
style of look so always remember uh when
you're doing any type of look
development don't just set your light
and then think that's going to make this
this image work if i just set one one
light move it
move it
up down left right rotate it a simple
rotation will also give you kind of a
different look so if i take this light
and let's say i rotate it back this way
now we have a completely different look
even though my character is still being
lit every look has been different simply
by making
random changes and uh into the so now we
have a different look so let's put that
back and let's like uh try
um let's try rotating it on its uh
side here although one second
and then let's rotate it on its
you know axis that way now
you kind of have this
weird
lighting where everything here is
completely in the darkness but you know
you know this is kind of in the in the
light and we have this
crazy long shadow that's coming under
the nose so always remember to try to
oh that's a different look too um
awesome but
like i said always try to
move your lights to get an understanding
of what's going on and we'll get a
better idea of how i do this once we
actually start lighting some of our
scenes in the next couple of videos
so with that being said these are the
different lighting setups when you come
into
uh this project file take a look at
these annotations that you see on the
side here i i put this together for you
guys to kind of reiterate
um you know what these different type of
lighting setups are
um when they're when they're best used
and uh you know how to how to utilize
those
so definitely check that out when you
actually get the project file so with
that said guys i hope you enjoyed this
one uh now we're going to start getting
you know putting this stuff into
practice
i i deem it very important for
any artist you know to fully understand
kind of like the different lighting
setups that were created by the masters
and the rules of that lighting and then
once you have an understanding of that
then you can start to make your own
rules and start to make your own kind of
lighting setups and kind of break those
rules and evolve uh the lighting um
you know the the the current lighting uh
scene that we have in motion design and
visual effects you may be that
individual who creates a whole new
lighting setup that just pioneers a
whole new level of filmmaking so keep
that in mind awesome i hope you guys
enjoyed it i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
[Music]
you